all right well thank you first of all
this title word post quando tog Rafi
what it means we're talking about
cryptography were we're designing the
systems under the assumption that our
attacker not the user just the attacker
has a large quantum computer also to
remind you from three years ago when we
showed you the attacker we talked about
attackers all right so we're seeing
right over the last few years 2015 say
middle August there was a big
announcement by the NSA saying oh yeah
actually the world should care about
post-conflict ography we need more
research they finally wake up to it and
next year they had a nice rollout of
fact that pretty much every agency just
highlight the three of them here so UK
Netherlands and the NSA themselves made
some statements about the urgency of
rolling out post kwanghoon that normal
cryptography that are currently using so
elliptic curves and RSA diffie-hellman
fine fields will be broken as soon as a
quantum computer and the NIST which is
the National Institute for Standards and
Technology so it's an institute in the
US which is working on standards
said okay we kind of call for a
standardization project for post
choreography so yes it's us institution
but it has in cryptography a mostly
given good history they have been
writing competitions which gave us a s
they've been running competitions which
gave us a three and they also without a
competition gave us dual EC so
competitions with NIST
good thing everything else well judge
for yourself this sounds like a great
story it's also a little bit
disappointing when you look at XI where
it started so back in 2003 then here
coined the term post quantum
cryptography and then they've been
running around for ten years going like
the end is nigh please invest in post
conquer talk we'd do something just that
ten years later the NSA says oh my god
we have to do something quantum
computers are counting so it's a little
bit yeah I told you so not a great story
all right so what happened with this
competition well after NIST said hey
everybody send us some proposals for
post-call crypto to standardize a lot of
people did so they said actually more
than 80 submissions came in and some of
them were incomplete like one of the
requirements was include software and
whatever reasons they said some of the
submissions are not complete but they
posted 69 complete submissions the
submission teams include 260 people from
around the world all sorts of academia
industry maybe even some government
people there's lots and lots of names
and we're not going to go through like
what all these things are but we are
going to say 60 minutes oh that's one
okay so big quake this is a code based
system no we're gonna give you some idea
of like what the big picture is of how
well these things have held up so these
were all posted - on the 21st of
December last year and some of you saw
our lattice hacks talk last year
remember that this list already there
was some damage to it by the time of our
talk on the 28th of December 2017 by the
end of the year there were eight
submissions that had attacks at
different levels of severity I should
explain the color coding here the stuff
that's in brown is less security than
claimed which could be for instance they
claim something was it would take 2 to
the 128th operations to break and
somebody says no it's 2 to the hundred
or two to the 80 well does that really
matter or maybe a different direction if
somebody says this is a system where you
can reuse the key any number of times
which we expect for for normal crypto
systems that you can publish your key
and people can keep sending you messages
or you can sign many times under some
keys but sometimes people claim they had
that feature and it they turned out to
be wrong that those were attackable like
gila 5 in this list which is not
necessarily kicking them out of the
competition because nist said you can
have a system with one-time keys that
can be useful for some applications the
things in red are everything that they
proposed all the concrete parameters are
broken the underlines are those where
there's attack scripts Python scripts
cage scripts whatever it takes to
demonstrate that yeah look here's here's
your secret key or decrypting something
so that was the end of 2017 how
out now well okay how let's extrapolate
three days from now
probably the situation is at least the
following at least by 28th of December
2018 22 submissions have attacks so it's
about a third of the 69 submissions and
you can see more well
most well 13 of those out of the 22 are
read mostly with underlines I think some
of this is from us a lot from other
people and I think we did well early on
establishing that people should put out
scripts to demonstrate that yeah you
really can break these things so again
the underlines are demonstrated attacks
some of the submitters have withdrawn
the broken submissions some of them have
not all right so when you look at this
it's been said we're not going to go
through explaining those but let me
categorize these so when we look at the
ones which are not completely smashed
and broken we can put them into boxes we
can say hey what is the underlying
mathematical problem what do we hope is
something the attacker has to do in
order to break the crypto system and
then there's one category of using error
correcting codes which is then used for
either building an encryption system or
signature scheme hash functions you can
only build signature schemes from a
certainty based crypto for the
competition we only see an encryption
system and honestly all the signatures
we have seen so far are pretty
inefficient that is this VC verbose that
is something we talked about last year
so if you want to get a full-blown
letters explenation go for last year's
talk and then finally there's something
using systems in many variables many
equations and we get signatures and
encryptions from that so that's one way
of saying well these are good things for
post one it does not mean that
everything which is in this boxes is
secure you can still design a system
which somehow relates to this math
problem but the attacker can do a way
around some of those systems records
I'll get back to later is a code base
system code base is on the list first
one up there so she'll be totally secure
and yet it's one of the red underline
systems so just being in one of the
categories categories does not mean it's
secure but
at least some hopeful helpful thing to
box things there are other ways of
describing why this is the situation we
have not as an example of this kind of
categorization sometimes people might
say Oh lattice paste cryptography is the
safe thing to do all of that read was
people who are not using lattice based
cryptography and everything the lattice
paste is good everything else is scary
but if you look at the lattice based
systems it's not all black there's some
red stuff here compact lwe that one is
broken where the script we're quite sure
it's broken there's some others with
some damage DRS heel of five so it's not
that the lattice base submissions have
held up perfectly and also it's not just
that these are isolated mistakes that
people have made there's ongoing
research which is making better and
better lattice attacks for instance some
papers from last month and this month
from the three authors listed there are
talking about lattice based systems
being broken by decryption failures now
this phenomenon most of the latus
submissions have occasional decryption
failures once every two to the 64
ciphertext maybe you won't be able to
decrypt which might sound like oh it's
no big deal it's it's maybe occasionally
you might have some user has that
happened and they'll just the browser
will reconnect whatever it takes it's
not a significant failure rate except
that those failures if the attacker is
trying to decrypt a particular
ciphertext or maybe even attack a figure
out somebody's secret key they can
usually get that information out of
watching the pattern of decryption
failures if decryption failures happen
often enough and these papers are saying
for two different reasons decryption
failures are actually happening more
often maybe much more often than people
claim so that's kind of scary
all right one explanation which I of
course like very much I've been running
a European protocol pick a crypto and
just use everything in our portfolio
it's good right actually it's looking
better than the arguments saying I'll
use everything lattice base we have one
which is slightly scratch but everything
else is good right okay except well
there's another explanation
than just well whoever these PQ crypto
project people are obviously the right
people putting together a great
portfolio there's another possibility
not saying this is right but you could
imagine that crypt analysts who are
deciding what to do out of that huge
pile of 69 submissions maybe they've
thought the people who were in this
project doing this stuff for some number
of years are maybe not the top targets
maybe you should look at the other 49
submissions maybe you should look at the
submissions with the specification
written in Microsoft Word probably more
likely to be broken maybe there's other
ways that you can decide how to no worse
than Microsoft people uh yeah that did
work coincidentally yeah so the thing to
keep in mind is that there's a huge pile
of submissions more than a million words
in these 69 submission documents and
this is like a word in English is
usually a kind of imprecise thing
reviewing that this is I would say more
effort than reviewing a million lines of
cooked this is a lot of stuff a lot of
junk to go through there's a real flood
there's too much for us to all the
people who care about attacking systems
to actually go through everything so
people are making a selection and maybe
they just haven't bothered looking at
these pica crypto submissions so if you
if you want to actually have security
review it's really important to keep
this denial of service effect in mind
that the the flood of submissions has to
be small enough that it can be handled
by the number of people who are looking
at these submissions and evaluating the
security so qualify help please join
please break don't break hours now one
thing which in this audience is a little
funny but in an all academic conference
we talk to like a 40 or 100 people we
like we actually have a lot of people
now being interested in posting
cryptography but this was this year's
conference on this when Ted and I
started this in 2006 we're looking at
the audience of 40 this is 350 people
all that would probably fit in here but
well for academics this is big there's a
huge interest right now this was the
combined conference together with a nist
workshop and so people are looking so
that's the good news
there's more than enough service going
I mentioned ruckus already as one
vicious protein but not withdrawn broken
actually three different ways where our
last message to them was basically
abandon all hope this is not going to
work but they keep on hoping if i zoom
in there they have they're on the way to
publishing new parameters when he was
reading it out actually at the
conference he was saying the keys and
signatures eyes may be several dozens of
terabytes well there is some effect that
we're most likely not gonna break it so
easily because when you're trying to
download several terabytes of data it
might not be connect so nest is
certainly aware of the fact that there's
just this denial of service on security
analysis and one of the ways that they
tried to simplify the picture it said
all right after the conference they put
out this call saying alright if you have
similar submissions see if you can merge
them and then hopefully you get
something which is you know going to be
a combined submission that's that's
easier for us to analyze than these two
separate submissions in the first place
and they said this is an interesting
little guarantee they said NIST will
accept emerged submission to the second
round if either of the submissions being
merged would have been accepted so you
can imagine kind of attacking this if
there's a strong submission and you have
a weak submission like the strong one
they surely have to accept that and then
you merge your weak submission into the
strong one if you can somehow convince
the other teams to do that then your
weak submission is also going to get
into the the second round but NIST said
well alright you should only merge
submissions that are similar and the
merged submission should be like a
combination of the two original
submissions so that sounds kind of
reasonable I example while the first
announcement of a merger
I don't think NIST said that you have to
publicly announce but he'll of five
merged with round two and of course this
was after the heel of five attack and
part of the merger was fixing the issue
in that attack and they formed round
five and they said round five this
result of the merge is a leading lattice
based candidate in terms of security
bandwidth and CPU performance so three
weeks later the
security turned out to be kind of a
problem Mike Hamburg said that here's a
very strong reason to believe that
decryption failures are much much more
likely than what they claimed and as a
result of that and they they accepted
the argument and said yeah as a result
of that like I mentioned before
decryption failures are something that
attackers can use to break security and
it's not that that a full attack was
implemented but it's pretty clear that
the attack would work and this is also
interesting attack because the mergers
were supposed to be just taking like
take the best features of your two
submissions that you're merging but this
was a mistake the vulnerability that
Hamburg exploited was a mistake that was
not in either of the submissions that
were being put together so there's some
process of break and fix and merged
making more mistakes which get broken
and then fix and what was the fix they
said I'll here's a proposed fix they're
looking at the security proof
adjustments there will be a round five
real proposal their actual merge will be
in the future I think now they have
round five a round five B and round five
C where a is broken B is questionable C
is still not defined what is a security
proof what is a security proof mean if
you have a security proof previously
that they were adjusting and the
security proof is for something that is
not actually secure very strange more
merger announcements post quantum RSA
encryption and post quantum RSA
signatures merged to form post quantum
RSA saying that that is a leading
candidate in terms of depth of security
analysis amount of network traffic and
flexibility for people not familiar with
post quantum RSA this means using RSA
with gigabyte or terabyte keys which is
leading in the amount of network traffic
we want the internet to have as much
cryptography as possible use more
bandwidth yeah remember you have if
you're measuring the amount of encrypted
data on your network this increases that
amount more mergers more mergers more
mergers some of these are kind of gluing
submissions together in a way that does
not simplify the the security analysis
but this last one is a good example I
would say of emerge enter hrs s and
enter encrypt to of the entry based
submissions they actually put some
thought into what they wanted to keep
and what they want to throw away and so
the analyzing the merge is easier than
analyzing the both of the initial
submissions after the November deadline
for mergers Nest said it will announce
the second round candidates maybe it'll
be probably less than 30 some hints
it'll be 25 or even 20 I candidates and
maybe that's starting to get down to a
small enough flood that we can start
seriously analyzing what's left they're
going to announce that I think on
exactly January 10th they're scheduled
to do that and then a week after this
announcement they said well the
government might be shutting down and in
that case we're not allowed to do any
work so we're going to be completely
silent in case of a shutdown it's
important in the US government during
shutdowns there's a definition of
essential personnel like NSA and
non-essential personnel like people
protecting us against NSA and only the
essential personnel are allowed to do
work you know what else is not allowed
to do work the backend database for NIST
webpages which might sound a little bit
weird although maybe they're paying
Oracle for the backend database and they
have to turn off the payments Oracle I
don't know what's going on here but they
if you look for the competition
information you can't find it on their
web pages anymore I we're not quite sure
how long the shutdown is going to last
of course there are some people who say
that this is not a problem because we
can figure out without this competition
how to protect ourselves against quantum
computer
all right now that we have earrings
already our quantum computers actually
coming a big question we don't know what
we can monitor is progress in quantum
computing and just mid of December there
was a news item from inq which is a
small startup company announcing their
largest ever quantum computer based on
iron traps all the other quantum
computers we've seen so far which other
of this size like 40 to 70 they were
using superconducting qubits so it is
again a race between different
technologies but both of them are
advancing and there some more which are
growing so it looks like it's coming
whenever I seen a picture like this a
reminder of a nice joke from a colleague
of mine Steven Galbraith
can you distinguish yep so with all
these news coming up the National
Academy of Sciences in the US has been
interviewing people for the last about
year-and-a-half so they got people in
physics and engineering building quantum
computers people doing quantum
algorithms people doing quantum vector
recruiting codes and putting all of this
together into a report which this came
out where they look into well what are
the progress and what the prospects so
the first part I have key findings the
first one is the good news saying don't
panic we do not expect that anything is
going to happen in the next 10 years
which will threaten RSA 2048 or similar
where I assume what I mean
while elliptic curves discrete log and
find fields so that's a good news but
the only I don't have just one key
finding it actually goes on two to three
ten by the time they reach ten I think
this is panic so what they say as well
it takes forever to roll all these
things it's a hazard of such a machine
that's high enough
them and then the deployment of post
quantum cryptography is critical for
minimizing the chance of a potential
security and privacy disaster these are
strong words from the National Academy
of Sciences so okay can we deploy post
quantum cryptography is it deployable
well some people would say we've already
deployed it but maybe that doesn't
include the NIST submission so let's
look at the deploy ability of the NIST
submissions the main thing that matters
for deployment in most applications the
main problem for post quantum
cryptography is the sizes so here's a
picture of the night sky over live
station now this is a picture of on the
horizontal axis is the size of your
public key for a bunch of signature
systems not all of the signature systems
for instance walnut DSA which is broken
with a script in the first five versions
a post quantum RSA is also emitted from
this sorry oh yeah that would be
I'm one of the designers of post quantum
RSA by the way it's the future of
cryptography that was good I yeah so
what you can see here is for example
this GUI submission this has you can get
your your vertical as the signature size
down to just 32 bytes or 35 bytes or
something like that but you need this is
something like 400,000 bytes in your
public key and then there's three
different dots for GUI those are three
different security levels and maybe the
all the different submissions here are
maybe not exactly comparable in the
security levels it should be a
three-dimensional graph if we measure
everything properly by exactly how
secure it is which of course we're not
quite sure about until there's been
enough security analysis you can see
various different trade-offs are
possible none of which are down where we
want to be with things like under a
hundred bytes for your public key and
under a hundred bytes for your signature
which is what we're used to right now
that's what elliptic curve cryptography
sizes which are both below a hundred
bytes and that's something you can fit
into your applications much more easily
than say a hundred thousand byte public
keys or ten thousand byte signatures
there's various different trade-offs and
maybe your application can handle some
of that but there's nothing that's just
really small which is what we're used to
right now another more complicated graph
this is for encryption and showing more
candidates while there are more
encryption submissions this is still not
all of the encryption submissions but
representative sample and you can see
that well there's still no really great
sizes here the best in terms of sizes is
psych super singular isogen e key
exchange which is something like 400
little less than 400 bytes for the
public key and for the ciphertext and
then it starts getting bigger from there
and you get on this graph you get things
up to megabyte or bigger you can get a
little below 3 400 bytes you can get
down to a hundred or so bytes for the
ciphertext as long as you are willing to
accept a public key that's much much
bigger with some of these code base
systems and then just to zoom in on some
of the smaller ones you can start seeing
where some different candidates are this
is everything which is public key and
cypher text below 1280 bytes and again
you see psych down there little below
400 bytes and then some other
possibilities but what are the security
levels of these things could all of
these be broken there's not actually
that many of them how many of these have
actually been studied it's kind of scary
and again much bigger sizes than we're
used to in cryptography so yes size does
matter
so Google and Cloud Fair this year in
April we're saying well we don't really
know what the outcome of this
competition is going to be but we have
some categories of different crypto
systems and let's just send dummy
packets of data of respective sizes and
see what happens when we do this on the
Internet now this is Google and
CloudFlare so they were doing this on
the Chrome browser for connections like
occlude through CloudFlare so they could
actually see from when I came where it
ended where they came back as I dropped
then mentioned psych so this is the one
category of super single I saw tonie's
those are just four hundred bytes and I
was pretty much fine so when you look at
the first column you have a small agency
increase you also see the inaccuracy
there's a minus 0.2 so the numbers are
mostly correct then there is in the
lattices this was a zoom in what the N
was showed those are mostly something
the category of structured lattices
those are around the MT used so one
hundred thousand two hundred something
bytes and that was mostly worked some
small increases about under 20% so this
is also something they feel like yes you
could actually deploy this on the
Internet then a different category is
still within lattices are unstructured
lattices those would come with 10
kilobytes of data for the public key and
there let us notice that too many pages
including like top pages on the lexa 500
such as LinkedIn were just dropping
they tried funny enough 9 thousand 999
were fewer pages dropping so 10k was
worse than 9,000 999
but even then LinkedIn was still
dropping and so that they crease it to a
third as base grab a placeholder
measured with these 3,300 bytes and then
scaled up by a factor of three now
those increases in the latency is what
they said well this is not acceptable so
then for the next experiments they were
only looking at ice our journeys in
structured lattices as such these are
also special not just being the smallest
but also being the slowest well okay not
absolutely the slowest but it's the only
system where the speed is much more an
issue than the size and so despite
Google having quite a few computers they
were saying we can't actually use ice
whole journeys for the speed reasons
size would be awesome but speed not so
sure it's also a relatively recent
systems just in 2012
so maybe also it's a security question
so just now in December they were
announced they actually building a new
experiment they announced which
candidate they have chosen and 2hrs S
which dentist mentioned was also one of
the reasons mergers and so this is one
of the structured lattices systems
designers are and has losing your
Steinfeld Peter Schwab and non skank
great score for Eindhoven team current
professor former student and then some
collaborators and so they're now
building a system which is a combined
elliptic curve so that's the combined
team that's combined elliptic curves and
post Kuan this is the second round
running and so this will come to some
internet browser near you soon another
nice result - it's not the only thing up
there
the ITF this year finished standardizing
X MSS which is a hash based signature
system um it's been in the making down
there used to the Time Bandits been
making for three years it's not really
fast but it's also the first of its kind
this was the first time that ITF has
published a post quantum are obscene
requests for comments but that's
basically their standards and so there's
a lot of boilerplate text which was
developed in this thing in the process
of making the standard which is dealing
with yeah post quantum quantum attacks
and so on how should handle it
exome assess is interesting it's not
honor the NIST submissions because
it doesn't satisfy the normal thing that
you learn in primary school what a
signature should be doing signature you
expect you have a public key you use it
to sign something and then you have a
signature X MSS you have a public key
you have a state you get a message you
sign it and you update your state and
you've ever forget to update your state
you will lose security so it's something
which is not as cool as a normal
signature scheme but there are also many
applications where you actually know how
many signatures you've made I mean if
you're doing operating system updates
you better know how often you got your
key out of the drawer and used it so it
is not impossible to use but it might
not be exactly what you want for your
web applications still if you can count
them the size is much smaller than the
signature systems another size advantage
size advance is something called
glowstick I should explain the name this
is starting from a lattice submission
called Sabre which is one of the
unbroken ones and Sabre has a big
version called fire Sabre high security
level scaled up it also has a small
version called light saber and this glow
stick is the even smaller version it's
like let's scale it down as far as we
can get that it's not quite broken and
there's various technical details and it
hasn't been broken in the months since
it's been proposed that six months or so
and it is interesting I mean it's
something which is a good challenge it's
it's nice to have these scaled-down
problems so we can try different ways of
attacking these things and people who
like breaking stuff it's it's good to
have the simpler systems to to practice
doing attacks and that gives you some
insight into what could work against the
larger systems so these are coming to
funny names oh no since they come in two
sizes why do we still care about big
sizes I mean people are scaling things
down Google says oh we don't like big
sizes so why do people say post phone
systems are bigger and we still care
about it so one of the reasons is well
highlighting mcLeese here
our submissions to this competition
these have had a lot of analysis so
classic mcLeese is based on the system
from 1978 basically unchanged except for
some changes where we can really prove
this is the same as that it has one of
the shortest cipher texts just two and a
bytes so that's actually kind of
tolerable on the Internet but a megabyte
of key key generations also put it slow
but then the well it's nowadays called
encapsulation decapsulation because all
you want is your a s key you don't want
to actually encrypt the message but
basic thing of encryption and decryption
of that so nice system very good history
in security pretty fast pretty small
except for the public keys it's like
Grandma why do you have so big case why
are these keys so big so one thing is
it's like a two dimensional key we have
there's big matrix there what you see on
the left is an identity matrix
this thing has about 7,000 columns this
is like pretty long it's only but the
height is n minus K which is just like
thousand five hundred so it's really
long and stretched and so all of this
part on your right hand side that part
is random and you have to send that you
can of course everybody remembers what
the identity matrix looks like you can't
forget about this one but this one you
have to send because the encryption
works by the sender thinking which of
those around 7,000 column he wants to
pick and then just X oaring them up and
for doing that well you need to have
this big matrix and if you calculate
well thousand five hundred forty seven
times five thousand four hundred
thirteen that's the part of the right
matrix you're getting to this one
megabyte size now what are the issues
was having big keys its bandwidth but
honestly when you download a pictures
also megabytes early it might not be so
bad I mean if you're on the German
trains then you will hate it but
normally also in the world or honey
mobile it's fine
Google was saying we actually excluded
Samson so they did an experiment was
classic McAleese large the look that was
10,000 kilobytes even then some dropped
and they said well some are too large to
be viable within TLS so they just said
well we don't do this but then again you
have a secure system you can just also
design a secure protocol to go with it
we don't need to stick with TLS but
there's a real problem was having a
megabyte of a megabyte of key because if
your protocol assumes that the client
generates there's 1 megabyte and then
just throws it at the server and the
server has to accept 1 megabyte from
every single client that is throwing a
megabyte at it and then has to do
something with it well this is read an
invitation for denial of service attack
because you allocating memory on the
server for doing these operations the
operations are pretty fast it's just ex
pouring zeros and ones but you have to
allocate one megabyte for each client
and so this is a problem now what about
the protocol we design we have to deal
with the possibility of denial of
service attacks or avoid them
so can service avoid storing these big
keys you want to XOR these columns so
one of the first limitation small
devices was saying well I'm a very small
device but I can pick those positions
and then outside role please be nice to
me and spoon-feed me one column at a
time so the small device memorizes
thousand five hundred bits I hope so
bill and then gets the next column if it
was selected it XOR zit in if it wasn't
selected well it keeps the intermediate
state so this works and at the end you
output the normal ciphertext but what we
have here is we operating in a friendly
environment where we do not expect this
outside world to do something nasty to
us and also we have some memory now we
put this on the real internet and we
don't want to have any
so we cannot memorize these thousand
find out because well we don't know when
the next column is going to come so we
output it sending us back to this client
that's not gonna work
when you tell the client oh this is my
current result then the client gets the
next color at the server gets an ex-con
maybe exhausted and maybe not send it
back to client
anybody who's watching this traffic
could see whether there was a change or
there was no change so this is not a way
of dealing with it
so whatever I've been busy with and well
I put a two thousand eighty was a
question why we still have like three
days right
so we working on a system called make
tiny tiny because it's made for tiny web
servers where we assume that this web
server is not allocating any Pro client
storage any Pro client state and so we
again work with spoon-feeding things but
we're making sure that everything that
the server gets and sends out is
encrypted is indicated there is some
stuff to avoid replay attacks so that
somebody can't just say oh what if I
change the column here there so all of
these things are encrypted and what we
do is we use properties of doing these
sums and pieces by chunking up this big
matrix into sharable pieces that are
small enough to fit in one MTU and still
have some space for some cookies so this
is similar to normal users of cookies
this is a cookie encrypted to the server
send to the client a client you handle
the storage and then the client sends
the next piece sends the old cookie now
the cookie is encrypted but the way that
the key is handled is the same for all
clients so there is no Pro client
storage of any keys it's a symmetric key
it's pretty small so that's the one
thing that the server remembers and then
it gets a packets it from this cookie
pod recovers all the like which columns
to pick what's intermediate result and
then does some computation sends it back
so the result of this is that we need
several round trips but there's
absolutely no client state on the server
of course you could say well there was
still all that bandwidth
and what if you do have been with
problems but some people say that we're
familiar with sending a lot of data
around so that's really not a big deal
something else that could interfere with
deployment is patents now Don you
mentioned before that classic McAleese
does not have patents but what if
somebody says I just don't want to
handle the megabyte or for whatever
reason people want something smaller or
there's thing that your questions well
we have a lot of information about some
systems which are patented the 18
systems shown here because NIST had as
one of the rules for the competition
that you had to deliver statements to
them signed by the every member of the
submission team saying either we do not
have patents patent applications on our
submission or here's the patents patent
applications here's their numbers and so
okay as a result of that and NIST's
after checking they had a complete pile
of statements put them online so now we
know that these are exactly the 18
submissions where the submission teams
claimed patents on their submissions
including for example compact lwe and
DME and walnut' DSA which are rapidly
broken by scripts that are online i and
RLC you come that one has half of the
parameters are broken there's another
half which are not broken it's not that
the patented submissions are somehow
better than the rest of the submissions
but well for some reason people think
they can make money off of patents and
maybe they're not actually so wrong
because you can't just throw away these
18 submissions and say that's the end of
it
problem is that there's some patents
which cover more submissions now this
does not require these submitters to say
that here's which patents are which
submissions are covered by my patent I
the submitters are only required to say
something about their own submissions
and also NIST has no way to say anything
about whatever random patent trolls that
are out there that have not submitted
anything they can't impose any rules on
that so I mean of course you can try
doing patent searches but you won't
necessarily find things for instance
this patent nobody noticed until it was
revealed in what by
of some submission teams this patent was
issued in 2015 at the top there which
might make you think all of something
was published before 2015 it would be
okay and some submissions were published
earlier but what's important is the date
down at the bottom here which is the
priority date of February 18th 2010 if
you look on Google patents one good
thing as they put the priority date
pretty far up where you can easily see
it what this means is that in order to
be prior art for this patent well you
have to check what exactly they filed in
2010 they might have made later changes
but the 2010 thing assuming that has all
the same stuff as the patent which it's
possible to find out I this anything
that was published after 2010 is not
prior art for this now what's really
scary about this patent and I hope that
really soon I'm gonna have analysis
online of which submissions are covered
by which patents of all the patents I've
seen this one is by far the scariest
because this one covers a whole bunch of
submissions this one covers basically
every submission which is using what's
called the LPR cryptosystem ring lwe
lattice based crypto systems this is a
very popular type of lattice based
crypto system which was published by LPN
R Luba chefs key peickert and reg EV in
May 2010 which is after this patent
application was filed now there was a
talk in April which had the same stuff
from LPR and it seems like there might
even have been a talk in January from
LPR but they didn't put the slides
online and then well it starts getting
into interesting questions with patent
law this looks like a very strong patent
covering a whole lot of submissions and
there's more cases there's a whole
company called Essaouira that is
specializing in planting landmines
patent land mines around things that
other people are doing
sometimes on things that other people
have already published and then you get
a court fight about it this is going to
be a problem it's something we really
have to watch out for is what is
patented and again I hope to be some
time soon done with some patent analysis
of course some people would
that we don't have to worry about
patents as long as we find something
that we can deploy that somebody tries
deploying it and they don't get sued not
sure that's going to be deployed anytime
soon I mean 3095 out of 3,000 okay
all right funny names I said so what do
you see here
anybody read phonetics yeah see side ok
so see side now see side is what you
really always wanted see side is an
efficient post one commutative group
action did you know that you wanted a
commutative group action actually you
did so what all people ask me is like
I'm using different harm on these days
what can you give me in the post cotton
world and then it depends a lot on how
you define you for Helmand some features
that we've come to use from Deva Harmon
are that well you publish a public key I
publish a public key other people
publish public keys and we can reuse
them kind of nice also we don't have to
talk to each other we can just look up
the other public key on the phonebook
have a shared key and start using that
one and if I send you something
encrypted with our shared some public
keys like combined thing of this then
you will be able to decrypt this there
are some nice other features you can
blind things you can like take your G to
the a and then multiply computer in the
exponent
times are so put some blind effectors
there and there is no difference whether
I'm the initiator or I'm the responder
in this we don't have this anywhere else
in post-punk cryptography all the
systems that you see for NIST
submissions make a difference between
are you the sender or the responder so
this is the first efficient post quantum
well different Harman like things which
well by fancy math called commutative
group action so if you're a user you
don't want to know all the details and
I'm gonna give it an entire talk about
this unless maybe next year what you see
exposed
to you is just one single find field
element so there's some fixed prime that
all the people in the system know and
then everybody's public he is just one
single field element so Emma's computer
field element Bob computes his field
element they post these somewhere and
then sometimes later years later maybe
of quantum computers build they find
each other they compute their shared
public he combined the shed the public
keys into their shared secret key sorry
and then they have says shared secret
now a little bit of the math behind this
ahe appears in some form there so this
is a one of the elliptic curves that
we've been talking about in gosh when
was this 2013 oh so no fortunately
looking so they say Y square equals x
cubed and then a this public key a X
square plus X and then what the
computation is to go from one key to
another key is using an ISO Janee same
isogen kind of thing that you heard in
psych before it's a math object which
just means you move from one elliptic
curve to another love the curve if
somebody tells you to implement this
what you need to get doing is well take
this prime P compute modulo P for
addition multiplications and divisions
all of those you for instance build and
all the curve operations and then some
more operations which computer I saw
Janee but all of those are just combined
from those things so there's nothing
particularly scary behind it
except for well we came up with this
thing in January 2018 at this lovely
beach what's great there but please
don't use it yet experiment with it all
you want but this has not had enough
analysis but another reason why you
might want this is security key sizes
and so on so so we're we're looking at
first of all how many keys are there at
all so how big do you have to look at
this P when you have fixed your prime P
say n bits then there are square root of
P so 2 to the N over 2 may
me such curves so these are the numbers
of public keys and then similar to how
the elliptic curve discrete log kind of
meet in the middle attacks work
so basically smart brute-force search
you get a square root of the number of
keys as a security so if you have square
root of P many keys
it takes you fourth root of P time to
find out what else is key is so if you
want 228 bit security you have to choose
your prime P four times as many bits so
a 512 bit prime but this is a talk on
post quantum cryptography so where do we
stand there elliptic curves would be
totally broken nicely enough for I
solder nice we don't have any complete
break there are some some exponential
attacks so it doesn't have full
exponential security as we maybe would
like to have on the other hand with RSA
and finally fueled if a human we have
been dealing with the growth of keys
with some exponent attacks so this is
something they're familiar with it
doesn't kill things but you look at the
literature it's most years and tortex so
we and also some others have been
looking into details I think our
analysis which we have at quantum that I
start in your talk is the most detailed
one looking into like what actual
secured you get against somebody was a
really really big quantum computer now
as elliptic curves you're hopefully have
also learned that you must always
validate you need get a point somebody
says oh this is my public key the first
thing you do is check is this thing on
the curve doesn't have the right order
same thing for isogen based crypto for
seaside you have a very quick check you
check that this curve has the number of
points you know what it is you don't
even need to do full point counting you
just take a point do some scalar
multiplications and you check it this is
another thing that we've gotten totally
used to doing this is another thing that
is really really really hard for most
post comment systems those postponed
systems you add another proof to it so
typically when you encrypt ooh
somebody's key and you're sending
something which looks like a key you
reveal all the secrets on there that's
why you can't reuse it or you have to do
a big zero knowledge proof to prove that
you
she generated this thing properly with
seaside just there all you do is check
it's a valid curve and you're done
besides it's also pretty neat so 32
bytes for the secret keys 64 bytes so
just twice as large as normal up the
coast that is really like bottom left
corner of dense graphics where there was
nothing
so Seaside does fill a big gap a big gap
is small there with something which pre
corner has at least 128-bit security and
post quantum so what miss was asking for
is comparisons with AES 128 and then you
look at like how big are the size is
hole because the quantum computers and
so on and we think that seaside 512 to
the best of our knowledge based on the
latest analysis will be as secure as
that there's some code written by
Lorentz somewhere now logan's hey this
is on skylake your mileage may vary this
is a it's not a super quick hack but
it's not deployment code so this is not
yet constant time there are some others
who've been working on constant time it
makes it about three times slower it is
similar to psych and that it's really
nice small keys but somewhat slow on the
other hand this is still very newest
just from January so we're still
figuring out ways to make it faster
whereas well psych has been doing a lot
of work getting to the speed that they
have now so there's hope that this will
get faster and there's some hope it will
remain a mine broke until next year but
well I'm not sure if I'm up with my
bunny at the thing at this moment I
think actually sees had a better chance
than psych of surviving but who knows
don't use it for anything yet speaking
of broke there's a lot of people who are
investing in crypto currencies
and I think I think it's Nick
matthewsons fault this whole quantum
cyber blockchain idea if you know
something earlier than 2016 well anyway
there's variations of it since then like
quantum AI blockchain apparently you can
buy the t-shirt we have about 10 minutes
left so I'd like to finish things off
with some comments on software now this
is looking back at 40 years of public
key cryptography while RSA was from 77
or so the big lease crypto system from
78 and then well here's some some
schematics of what the software quality
has been in cryptography on a scale of
good bad terrible and horrifying 1978 I
don't actually know I haven't seen
software from back then by 1988 it was
clear that the software quality was
horrifying by 1998 it had moved up to
terrible by 2008 it moved up to bed and
by 2018 it has jumped back down to
horrifying
[Music]
and of course a major contributor to
this is all of these NIST submissions
which have code written by
mathematicians who barely can implement
anything and certainly don't have good
code quality there's occasional
submission teams that have people who
can write code but in general if you
well for a good time technically and
that's fine yeah yeah the classic
mcLeese code is fine there's other
submissions where the code is is fine
but if you just take a random submission
and look at the code it's well
interesting if you would like to find
out where the software is and download
it yeah this doesn't work very well I
did look archive.org has like you know
search for nist round one on DuckDuckGo
and the top link is to the NIST page and
then you take the URL for that put it
into archive.org and i tried a few of
the the submissions and the zip files
that nist prepared with the
specifications and the code those are
available from archive.org I guess they
got most or all of them you can also
look for more than half the submissions
there are upstream websites with new
error code NIST has not updated the code
but lots of submissions the submission
teams have lots of the fastest code and
even some faster well improved code is
available in our Supercop benchmarking
framework so this is the system for
unified performance evaluation related
to cryptographic operations in
primitives bench CR Y PTO and this one
has well a hundred seventy primitives
from 40 of the 69 submissions might have
accidentally left out all of the
patented submissions Wow the super call
policy is anybody who sends us code to
put in will it will benchmark it it
doesn't have to be unpatented doesn't
have to be secure we benchmark md5 we
benchmark RSA 512 but well anyways
there's 40 submissions where code is in
there from other people or from me
painfully going through getting code to
actually work the primitives are for
instance RSA 512 and RSA 1024 in RSA
2048 they're all RSA but they're
different primitives or different
mathematical functions with different
security
levels and well in these submissions
there there's typically three different
security levels sometimes more choices
sometimes less and then a lot of the
primitives have multiple implementations
like reference code and optimized code
for different platforms maybe so okay a
lot of those are collected in this
benchmarking framework all with the same
API lid PQ crypto I think I might have a
few minutes to say a little more about
this let Picou crypto is focusing on
having an API which is suitable for
cryptographic deployment in the future
if you imagine that the implementation
quality of the underlying crypto is
dramatically improved at least that
interface layer is supposed to be
something that we will be able to use
some more examples of things out there
PQ m4 is a library optimized for small
arm microcontrollers the arm cortex-m
for p q HW is for FPGAs and this last
one open quantum safe that one they
don't have as many primitives maybe as
loop PQ crypto or super cop but what's
cool about that project is they've got
working integrations of all of these
into open ssl and open SSH so if you're
in say the TLS world then that's clearly
the way to use these post Quantum
proposals at least quite a few of them
inside
TLS okay let me look a little bit at lib
PQ crypto and then we'll finish this off
I there's lots of cryptographic
libraries which give you a nice simple
API for hashing they'll have some simple
function like sha-256 which takes a
message okay and C you have to say
there's a pointer to the beginning of
the message plus length of the message
and then gives you back some hash of
some 256 bit 32 byte hash in a
higher-level language of course you say
something like H equals sha-256 of M and
M knows what it's like this but in C it
looks like you have H and M and the
length of m as arguments why not do this
for all cryptographic functions somehow
it's really weird lots of cryptographic
libraries just have a nice simple
interface for hashing and then if you
want to do something like public key
signatures it's well okay first we're
going to find the factory which is
producing the keys while the the
generator
for the key blah blah blah and well you
can just say and what lid PQ crypto does
is it simply says you sign something
with whichever signature scheme you have
to tell it well I'm gonna put the signed
message somewhere and then the length of
the message is an output the message
you're signing in the length or inputs
and your secret key is an input and then
it just takes everything in wire format
produces everything in wire format you
don't have to have conversion functions
and put output C realisations etcetera
this is actually an API that goes back
to we've been doing Supercop for many
years and Supercop the salt library lib
sodium etc are all using the same API
and this is something which actually
people have measured the impact on
usability of cryptographic libraries
depending on the different API provided
by these libraries and so we're pretty
confident about benefits of having a
nice simple way to use crypto this
looked at this and said well okay yeah
people should submit something in to the
post quantum competition using this API
but they didn't have test code that
people could use to make sure that they
were they were following the rules they
didn't require that everybody pass any
particular set of tests and they
accepted submissions which didn't work
for example in Supercop so well okay
that's why I had to do a bunch of work
to integrate a bunch of submissions into
into Supercop but it's been sufficiently
close to everybody using this that there
has been a lot of code shared between
these different projects open quantum
safe is also starting from the same API
and then providing higher-level
integrations into open SSL and open SSH
all right okay there's a bunch of
different signature systems and a bunch
of different encryption systems in
Latika crypto here's an example of what
the higher-level API looks like in
Python if you want to use lead pica
crypto and sign a message
well first somebody has to generate a
public key and a secret key using the PQ
crypto library signature system here's
one of the signature systems Sphinx is
stateless hash based signature system
you don't have to record anything when
you sign message and then 128 is
security level two to the 128 using the
2:56 ash and well you just have to know
this name and then you say give me a key
pair sign a message using a secret key
open a message using a public key now
this is not you get a signature and then
you do verify of a message and a
signature this is another little API
detail designed to protect people
against screwing up there's lots of
applications which verify signatures and
then if the verification fails nobody's
ever tested it and the verification
failure is ignored what actually works
to protect application programmers is
have an interface where you have a
signed message as one bundle it goes
into the opening a signature opening a
signed message and producing a message
and the cryptographic library does not
produce a message as output if the
signature was invalid
so the signed message is produced is is
handled by the cryptographic library
producing a message if the signature is
valid also there's an exception being
raised but even if you ignore the
exception in Python or if you're using a
lower level language without exceptions
then you just aren't given back a
message this is lots of little thought
that goes into the API ah maybe a bigger
example in Python this is a whole thing
of using library generating a key
signing some random message and opening
the message okay what's going to happen
in LED peak your PQ crypto coming up is
first of all one of the big problems
with code quality is there's lots of
exposure to timing attacks I saw a great
talk earlier today about Specter and
there's lots and lots of these attacks
and part of fixing these attacks is
fixing software along with we're gonna
have to do lots of hardware fixes
there's been some work on some
implementations to fix this but much
more is required need a lot more work on
correctness lots and lots of the code
doesn't even pass address sanitizer and
this was I don't want to tell you how
much pain to get code working and
address sanitizer where I mean anybody
writing code professionally is going to
be using these automatic tests as
they're writing the code and this is
something that just doesn't happen when
you ask a bunch of mathematicians to
write code formal verification will do
much more
testing and do much more than say
address sanitizer does and much more
than even an expert auditor will do that
formal verification is going to
guarantee that your code is doing what
it's supposed to for every possible
input which I used to be very skeptical
about because it seemed so painful to do
for any realistic code but I've started
getting much more enthusiastic about it
because the tools are getting much much
better and one example of something I
did was sorting verification where some
really fast sorting code is actually
completely verified to work correctly
the machine code is verified so you
compile it even if there's compiler bugs
then the machine code is what's verified
so that the verification isn't going to
rely on some compiler being correct this
is using the anger toolkit also I don't
know if there's any trail of bits people
here Manticore I understand has similar
features I used anger but well there's
really cool tools out there for doing
symbolic execution and as part of that
formal verification speed is important
and trying to get the code volume down
there's lots of duplication we need more
internal libraries to get post quantum
krypton a small or easier to review
codebase and finally hopefully at the
end of all this we'll be able to throw
away as many primitives as possible and
focus on a small number of things where
we can say we've really seriously
reviewed these we've reviewed the
designs we reviewed the implementations
and we're confident that these things
are secure that's it thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]